no surprise demand for comfort food has  spiked during the pandemic the group top  data it's more from them they say demand  for cookies went up 25 percent  in fact one in five americans admit to  eating more than three  cookies a day it's been a big boost for  cookie makers as they turn their treats  into big business  everyone wants a personalized dozen  for their special someone because they  can't have a party or because they can't  go anywhere  desserts sugar anything that tastes good  is something that people want to bring  to the kitchen  and want to bring their family towards  during this pandemic because it's a  comfort  so we eat more cookies and i guess we  work out more hopefully that's what  happens  have a good rest of the day we'll check  in with you tomorrow take care of  yourself